last week believe you urged
consideration of the federal inmate
population given the coronavirus where
does that stand now given the concerns
about the spread of the virus inside
state prisons and obviously federal
facilities we're not going to open our
prisons and let prisoners go free are
are generally our our mission is to
protect the public and we're not going
to do anything that's contrary to that
where we find a prisoner who is
vulnerable because of their age and
their medical condition that has served
the substantial part of their sentence
that has not been convicted for a
violent crime or sexual crime does not
pose a threat to the community
we're using every tool we have to put
them in home confinement provided we
think home confinement will not be more
dangerous than staying where they are
and also after a quarantine period where
we can ensure that they're not taking
the disease in to the public you have
been criticized recently for focusing on
the drug cartels during the kovat virus
this issue of drug cartels it doesn't
feel like that is the frontline concern
of every American right now might seem
like an odd thing yesterday to be
talking about drug cartels it's not top
of mind for the health care workers who
are on the front lines of this Chuck and
for so many Americans well it might come
as a surprise to some of these people
that the federal government the the
Justice Department specifically has
115,000 people who are dedicated to
protecting the public safety including
preventing narcotics trafficking and
we're actually able to do more than one
thing at a time and we're handle
handling different kinds of cases maybe
fraud is not on the top of their mind
but we still police fraud it's very
interesting because drugs killed 70,000
Americans a year 70,000 a year and it's
poison and we have to make sure that
during this period the cartels are not
taking advantage of the United States
and pumping this poison up into the
United States and the borders getting
tougher to penetrate now and so they're
coming in via boat and navigable
waterways to get into the United States
right and they're relying more on boats
to bring the cocaine up from from South
America up for further transportation
into the United States and and so the
Justice Department can do more than one
thing at once and and I'm amused
whenever I say you know bar has
intervened in this case or bar has done
such and such at the time of the Kovach
rights business for the Department of
Justice has to continue John Brennan has
come out smashing the president's firing
of Inspector General Michael Adkison
let's listen and also I think trying to
send a signal to others mr. Truong
continues to show his insecurity in
terms of trying to stop anybody who is
going to expose again the lawlessness
that I think he not only has allowed to
continue but also that he at best I
think the President did the right thing
and removing Atkinson from the vantage
point of the Department of Justice he
had interpreted his statute was a which
is a fairly narrow statute gave him
jurisdiction over wrongdoing by
intelligence people and tried to turn it
in to a commission to explore anything
in the government and immediately
reported to Congress without letting the
executive branch look at it and and
determine whether there was any problem
he was told this and in a letter from
the Department of Justice and he is
obliged to follow the interpretation of
the Department of Justice and he ignored
it so I think the president was correct
in firing him and it's a second
Inspector General he's fired since the
beginning of this pandemic and of course
that's used to say well the president
doesn't want to watch dogs alright I
think that's true I think he wants
responsible watchdogs what can you tell
us about the state of John Durham's
investigation people have been waiting
for the final report on what happened
with this
what can you tell us well I think a
report you know may be and probably will
be a byproduct of his activity but his
primary focus isn't the prepare report
he is looking to bring to justice people
who were engaged in abuses if he can
show that they were criminal violations
and that's what the focus is on and as
you know being lawyers yourself building
these cases especially the sprawling
case we have between us that went on for
two or three years here it takes some
time takes some time to build to build
the case so he's diligently pursuing it
my own view is that the evidence shows
that we're not dealing with just
mistakes or sloppiness there was
something far more troubling here and
we're gonna get to the bottom of it
and if people broke the law and we can
establish that with the evidence they
will be prosecuted president is very
frustrated I think you you obviously
know that about Andrew McCabe he
believes that people like McCabe and
others just were able to basically flout
laws and so far with impunity I think
the president has every right to be
frustrated because I think what happened
to him was one of the greatest
travesties in American history without
any basis they started this
investigation of his campaign and even
more concerning actually is what
happened after the campaign the whole
pattern of events while he was president
so I to sabotage the presidency and I I
think that or at least had the effect of
sabotaging the presidency
well FISA abuses really be prevented
going forward given what happened here
where FISA judges are not given critical
pieces of information material facts
about evidence that inform the
government's okaying the surveillance of
American citizens I think it's possible
to put in a regime that will make it
very hard either to willfully circumvent
fries
or to do so sloppily without due regard
for the rights of the the American
person involved and also to make it very
clear that any misconduct will be
discovered and discovered fairly
promptly so I do think we can put in
safeguards that will enable us to go
forward with this important tool I think
it's very sad
and the people who abused FISA have a
lot to answer for
because this was an important tool to
protect the American people they abused
it they undercut public confidence in
FISA but also the FBI is an institution
and we have to rebuild that